>> ALAMI: My name is Ossama Alami. I'm a developer
advocate at Google. I work on our Geospatial
APIs, Google Maps, Google Earth. How many
of you were not in my session this morning?
Okay, great. So, most of you were, that's
good. I'm going to build up on some of the
stuff I talked about there. But if you weren't
you'll definitely learn something new. So,
let's see. You can follow me on Twitter. It's
ossamaalami. And you should definitely follow
googlemapsapi on Twitter as we tend to announce
a lot of things that way. What I want to talk
about during this session is sort of a bit
of grab bag. We have a lot of different Geospecial
APIs at Google and I'm trying to fit, you
know, about a year's worth of what's new into
this one talk. In the earlier talk, I talked
a lot about Maps API v3. I'll touch about
one other new feature in v3 and some of other
mapping APIs you may not know about. I will
give you a very brief overview of all of our
Geo APIs. And then, Fusion Tables, which you
probably haven't heard about, but is pretty
exciting. I'll talk about some new things
in Latitude--I'm sorry, in Earth in KML and
the Latitude API. So, when you think about
Google Geo or Google Maps, you probably think
about our JavaScript Maps API, which certainly
it has the largest usage in all of our Geospatial
APIs. But we have more than just a JavaScript
Maps API for let's call it "visual" rendering
of Geospatial data. We also have a Maps API
for Flash. So for action script developers,
for developers who want to take advantage
of the futures of Flash or who are programming
in that environment, we do have a mapping
API that fits your needs. I don't know if
any of you are Flash developers or dabbled
some. There is one cool feature in the Maps
API for Flash that is not in any of our other
mapping APIs and that's the ability to do
a 3D perspective. So using the geographic
or the graphic rendering capabilities of Flash
we are able to tilt the map and give some
perspective. It's still a flat map but we're
able to tilt around, you know, camera angle
and give the user some perspective. So this
is just a sample animating a drive down the
coast of Australia, putting in--pulling in
some imagery from Panoramio. We also have
a Static Maps API. This is sort of the most
basic mapping API that you can think of. It
is just an HTTP get request. It returns an
image. If you've used the maps, the Static
Maps API before, there are a couple new features;
the ability to Geo code inline, the ability
to do custom markers. These are new features
we've added in the last year. A lot of people
use the maps, the Static Maps API, for either
smartphone--or non-smartphones, phones that
have a web browser but don't have a capable
web browser of rendering JavaScript. You still
want to deliver a map to that device. Or when
you're map isn't part of your Core UI, right?
It's some data off to the side that's interesting
to a user but you don't really expect the
user to interact with it. The Static Maps
API is super fast because all it's doing is
loading an image and rendering that, it's
not doing any sort of JavaScript. So, you
see up here the URL is just maps.google.com/maps/API,
instead of JS to load the JavaScript Maps
API at Static Map. And then the parameters
are all passed in via URL parameters right
here. So if I change this to, for example,
zoom level 17 and make the map a little bit
larger and say, "I want a hybrid map," I can
do that. Network is a little bit slow. And
you can see I just generate that static image.
It's not a slippy map it's just an image.
Oops. And we also have Earth API, so a way
to embed Earth in their browser and JavaScript
or API around controlling that experience.
I'll talk about that a little bit later in
this talk. What else is there? This is not
an exhaustive set of APIs that Google offers
that have some sort of Geospatial component.
We have something like a hundred different
developer products that Google currently develops
or as an API to of those, many of them have
some sort of Geospatial component. These are
some you may not have heard of or some more
of the commonly used ones. We have a web service
for some of our Geospatial services like Geocoding,
Elevation and Directions. These are services
that are offered natively in the JavaScript
Maps API and the Flash Maps API. But outside
of that, you can access these services via
just a HTTP get request, pass in some URL
parameters, get the results back. Geocoding,
I covered earlier in the earlier session.
But Elevation and Directions, both have some
new features. For example, Elevation is an
entirely new API that we're offering. It lets
you give us a latitude and longitude or a
polyline, and will return to you the elevation
at that point, or if you're passing as a polyline,
the elevation along a sampling of that polyline.
So you can now have access to Google's Elevation
data. Directions, in addition to adding an
HTTP Direction Service, which is brand new
since May, we didn't have a web service to
gain access to Directions. The Directions
service also does things like solving the
traveling salesman problem. So, route optimization.
If you give it ten locations and say, "I want
to walk between these ten. Give me the best
routes between these ten," it will optimize
that to minimize the travel time. Fusion Tables,
I'll talk about later in this talk, as well
as Latitude and KML. Panoramio is a image
hosting sites but it's purely focused on Geo
tagged photos of high quality panoramic images
of a place. That's why that example earlier
pulled an imagery fit from Panoramio because
everything there is Geo tagged and it's typically
of high quality. And, of course, we also have
native Mapping APIs on the iPhone Map Kit,
which is actually supported Apple, but uses
our data and Map View on Android, which is
a native mapping API for Android. So, new
maps features. The most--so, we released a
thing called Styled Maps in May and at Google
I/O. This enables you more control over the
map than you have ever had before, more than
any other major mapping provider on the Web
gives you. Before, you obviously had control
to play around with any--with the controls
on the map, add your own control, style them
however you want. Now, we're giving you the
ability to style the base map itself. So if
you look at this map, it is just San Francisco
and the standard Google Map's look and feel.
But I'll run through a couple of different
styling options. Here's a grayscale map. And
you see it's still a slippy map, it loads
in new tiles. Here is one that's slightly
desaturated. I don't know if that comes across
on the projector. Here's an ugly one. If you
noticed the difference between these two,
not only are we giving you the ability to
style the map but we're also giving you the
ability to remove features. So here, I have
non-major roads and here I don't. So, you
can, A, style the entire map; B, remove features
on the map, and C, style specific features.
So, you can change coloring of features only,
so if you wanted to change the color of the
water or change the color of major roads.
Let's take a look at some examples of that.
Here is sort of a nighttime feel map. Here,
I've turned all the parks pink and now all
blue--all green. Here is just another sort
of look and feel to a map. So, why would you
want to style the map other than it being,
you know, kind of cool? There are a couple
of things that we think are really compelling
and really useful to have style maps for.
One is if you're representing data on top
of the map, let's say you're putting polygons
on the map and you want to, you know, let's
say that they're polygons representing--polygons
of different shade representing some sort
of intensity, right, and you're showcasing
a big area like the entire country of Brazil,
it doesn't really make a lot of sense for
you to have local roads on the map. It just
takes away from what you're trying to get
across. So by enabling you to remove features,
you can let your data whatever your mash up
is, rise to the surface, gain more visibility,
and become more usable. The other reason is
if you want to fit a look and feel of a brand,
right? So you don't--you no longer have the--have
the look and feel of our Google Maps brand,
you can have a look and feel of whatever brand
you want to represent. Oops. Here is one highlighting
transit routes. And here is one, for example,
where I just turned everything, the--all the
landmass to this gray color and everything
else black. So, a lot of different options.
Pretty powerful. And I'll show you what this
code looks like. Well, first of all, we give
you option for styling to change the saturation,
the gamma, the lightness, the hue and it just
invert the lightness. So what does this code
look like? It's basically just a style array.
Here, what I'm doing is I am taking--I'm saying
for local roads, for the geometry of those
local roads, change the hue to this green
color and change the saturation, I want it
100% saturated. So, element type, such as
geometry, the other things that that could
be are labels or both geometry and labels,
so you can style the labels separately from
the geometry. And here, I'm doing landscape
geometry, changing the hue. I can also turn
features on and off. So I basically build
this style array and I create a new styled
map type in the Maps API v3. And I pass in
the style array, I pass in the map and I give
it a name and then I add it to the map types
array and give it a key. And then if I it
want to show up by default as the default
map type, then I just set map type ID. And,
really, that's it. It's that simple. So, this
is--this was launched, the Maps API v3, in
May of this year. And the Maps API for Flash,
we launched this feature I think something
like three weeks ago. And today, we are launching
this in Static Maps. So you now have the ability
to style Static Maps and that's something
we're launching right--today. The code for
this, again, pretty simple, it just takes
in a series of styles over here that are type
eliminated; so geometry, the hue, the saturation,
lightness. And then, we also have--let's see.
Here is it. We also have a Maps API Styled
Maps Wizard where you can go build styles,
play around with different styles and then
very easily export that JSON configuration.
You can make many, many ugly and unusable
maps so I encourage you to tweak it so that
it's as usable as possible. You know, we're
giving you the power to change the map type
and you have the power to make it look terrible.
Please don't. But I'll show you how this works.
So, let's say for some crazy reason I wanted
to change the water red. I wanted--sorry.
Let me see if this will speed up and then
add that style. I want to--let's go to Sao
Paulo. Great. Turns out this network cable
is not working, okay. Sorry. Come on. Always
has to be some sort of breakdown. There you
go. That should work. Apologies about that.
So, let's try this again. Add style--that's
quicker. I, for instance, want to turn off
all the local roads and all the highways I
want it to simplify and let's say the entire,
well administrative, let's say I want to simplify
all of that. So you see it got rid of the
major labels, as I zoom in it'll--the labels
will show up, and I want to over-saturate
everything. And here we have a map. And if
I just hit show JSAN I can copy and paste
that code directly into your Maps API implementation.
So it's really that easy and I encourage you
to play with this feature. The--another new
thing I wanted to show you is Fusion Tables.
Does anybody heard of Fusion Tables? Okay,
nobody. Oh, no, a couple people. Fusion Table
is something we just launched out of Labs
a couple weeks ago. And it is essentially
a relational database sitting in the cloud
that has a really strong notion of Geospatial.
It's great for storing and visualizing all
sorts of data but it has native support for
a lot of Geospatial types and KML. So, I mean
I'll walk through a couple examples of Fusion
Tables. Here is my Fusion Tables accounts.
I earlier found this dataset. I tried to find
a dataset for Brasil but I couldn't find a
good one, so I got this dataset from the United
States. The United States is separated into
something like 450 congressional districts
and every year a government organization releases
a lot of demographic information broken down
by congressional districts. So this just a
CSV download that I uploaded into Fusion Tables.
Fusion Tables split it out into a tabular
format. I don't have any sort of geo data
in here, I just have the district name and
then a bunch of different fields. So if I
look at the columns, you see I have median
age, the total population, total population
who are Asian alone, not born in the U.S.,
et cetera, et cetera. There's a lot of data.
And down here at the end I have a two digit
district code. So, I have the district name
and a two digit district code. Let's take
a look at some of the options Fusion Tables
give you just for visualizing large datasets
like this. So this is going to have, what,
436 rows. I can pick a way to visualize. Let's
say I want a line chart. The X axis I want
to be the district and the Y axis let's say
the median age of the total population. But
I can change this to any of the options or
I can highlight multiple and you'll see it
collapses a lot of districts but they're in
order. So you can see the outlier here appears
to be somewhere in between Michigan and Alabama.
But this is the median age of these different
congressional districts. So let's say percent
of the total population who are 85 and older
and not surprisingly, Florida is the outlier
here. A lot of people retire in Florida in
the United States. There's--there are other
things I can do. I can do a pie--a bar chart.
I can then say median age of total population
and combine these things. So that is, I mean,
a really, really fast way to visualize lots
of data. And what's really cool about Fusion
Tables is you see I can get an embed code
here. Fusion Tables has a notion of sharing
and collaborating over a tabular dataset.
So, I have sharing options in Fusion Tables
like I would in Google Docs. So let's say
I want to--I make it unlisted so anybody with
the link which also enables the embed code,
or I could just make it public which means
it's searchable within Fusion Tables itself.
Click, get the embed code, copy paste and
I'm done, right? I have that visualization
if I update my table, my visualization updates,
pretty cool. And since this is a developer
day, I'm not going to spend a lot of time
on the copy paste. Let's take a look at another
dataset. So, that dataset didn't have any
notion of Geospatial. Let's take a look at
a dataset from Brazil. It is a list of public
beaches in Brazil and their latitude and longitude.
So latitude and longitude is already in this
table, but if you had say a CSV that you uploaded
that just had you know, name, some attribute
information, and address, Fusion Tables will
automatically geocode that for you so that
it has a reference to where that actually
is on the planet. You don't have to upload
geocoded data to Fusion Tables if you want
to use its Geospatial features it'll do that
automatically. So not much to this table just
that I can click visualize the map and I think
there are something like 2000 beaches listed
here. I can click on one and I'd see, you
know, like, it gives me the beach name and
the title of the table, that's because I actually
went in earlier and configured the info window.
So I wanted the name and the table name, I
can configure it to be whatever. So if I go
back to defaults, it'll default to all the
data in the table. So this is pretty cool.
What's really, really hard in using the Maps
API is representing lots and lots of data,
drawing lots and lots of points on the map.
And the reason for this is the way you add
markers to a map, it's all through JavaScript.
So as you add a thousand markers that is at
a minimum, a thousand DOM elements, more likely
much more than that and in JavaScript when
you pan the map the Maps API has to take care
of panning all those markers at the same time.
So it's a big performance hit. The way Fusion
Tables does a maps integration is by tiling.
So these dots you see, they're actually all
256x256 tiles, the same tiling scheme as the
Maps API itself. And these tiles are burned
on to--sorry, these dots are burned unto tiles
that are transparent that sit on top. And
then they're made interactive through JavaScript.
JavaScript is very, very fast that--at hit
testing, right? "In this coordinate, am I
over something that's interesting?" And passing
that data is not a lot of data even for 10,000
points. So we can do what Fusion Tables does
is, you know, as I mouse over, it's in JavaScript,
evaluating it, it knows that there's a point
there. So another cool feature, I don't know
if you guys have ever tried to do heat maps,
there's a lot of the various API's and software
that does that. But Fusion Tables has this
check box here and I have a heat map. Incidentally
this island looks quite nice and so, is it
a popular beach resort? It seems to have a
lot of beaches. So Fusion Tables lets you
plot a lot of points on the map and visualize
it, lets you do heat maps very quickly, lets
you collaborate over sets of data. All right,
so let's go back to that old dataset I had
of a congressional district demographics.
You know, it's an interesting dataset, it
has a lot of information, but really it has
a notion of place, right? Congressional districts
are real places in the United States, so it's
interesting in visualizing this data, it would
be really interesting visualizing this data
on the maps somehow. But I don't have that
map data. So I'm going to search Fusion Tables.
A lot of people make Fusion Tables--their
data public and I just happen to know that
there is a shape of U.S. congressional districts
boundaries for the 110th Congress. So all
this table has is just the ID, the states,
and name for that district, and then this
short form ID. It so happens that the short
form ID is also the short form ID that was
in my other table. And then it has a shape.
So if I click here you can see that Fusion
Table supports polygon rendering as well.
It supports KML. You can upload KML and it'll
render KML on the map. What I want to do is
merge this tables. So if I could just click
this merge button, shape of U.S. congressional
districts. I know I want to merge on the ID.
I have this table here. I know that the short
two digit district is right here. Why don't
we call it GDD BR table demo one. I hit merge
table
and all of the sudden the table is merged.
I have this shape data and if I move over,
you see, I also have all the population data.
So that's cool. What can I do with this? Well,
one of the visualization options here is map.
I can click visualize map. It is generating
it. There we go. And it's drawn the 435 Congressional
Districts, the polygons, all through tiles.
This is something else that's really difficult
to do just in JavaScript in Maps API. And
all the data is still there. So if I click
on Wyoming, I get this gigantic info window
of all the stats. There's also some really
cool ways to visualize the data. You know,
this is interesting, you know, and maybe an
interesting way to interact with Fusion Tables.
But let's say I have a mash up that I really
want to get some type of data across, some
concept. I want to visualize, you know, average
ages of congressional districts. So I can
click through, I can customize the info window
so that it only shows average age. But I can
also configure styles, so you can configure
styles from markers or polygons. So, these
Brazilian beaches if I had some other attribute
that I wanted to show a different type of
marker for that beach versus another beach
I could very easily do that. In this case,
I want to change the fill color based on some
sort of gradient, let's say from 30--well,
let's say from 25 to 35. I'm going to select
the column, median age of total population,
let's say 40. I really only want three steps;
let's say red for the older, blue for the
younger, yellow in the middle and it generates
its gradients. Let's save, give it a little
chance to churn, and there we go. So you can
see districts over here a little older. Here,
very young, for some reason. And that's--I
mean, that's really cool. You couldn't do
that easily before and now we have a cloud-based
offering that lets you load this data and
render it however you want. You know, let's
configure this. I'm sort of not kind of a
sucker for transparency because it looks cool,
so why don't we make this slightly transparent.
And now, I can see the underlying map. So,
a couple of places we've seen this used. One
is if you're familiar or following the news
on the WikiLeaks, they--the Guardian took
that leak dataset, and then using Fusion Tables,
mapped basically every record they had of
Iraq, deaths in Iraq, on a map. This, sadly,
is a huge dataset. And rendering on a map
would be quite difficult if it weren't for
Fusion Tables. So all--the Guardian date was--load
this data in Fusion Tables and then copy that
embed code and placed it on their site and
allow for some interactive way to explore
that dataset. And it is loading quite slow.
But you can see there's, you know, the one
tile has come in and you can see how the tiling
works. Another thing the they, the Guardian,
did is it added this link where you can download
the data directly from them and get the data.
And you see here they have a link to download
details of every death in Iraq. Google Fusion
Tables, click that link. And here's the dataset.
So this is their table. I can't play around
with their table. I can visualize it and,
you know, perform some sort of aggregation.
So, maybe I didn't show this like go to a
line charts [INDISTINCT] wounded over day
and time, but there's also a ton of aggregation
options you can do. But what's really interesting
about this--oh, I'm not signed in. Let me
copy this to my other browser. All right,
I'm signed in. I can't customize anything
on this, but they allow this table to be exported.
I can file, create view, save as WikiLeaks.
I saved the view, copy the data I want. This
is now a view to their data where I can configure
styles however I want it to show up. I can
play with the columns, play with the data.
But it still reflects their data so they change--make
a change and it's changed on my table as well.
And just to show you how many records there
actually are and how many records or points
were rendered on that map. There are 52,000
records. So, that is a substantial amount
of points. So, what I've shown you so far,
all the things I've shown you, you know, are
pretty interesting, but it's all about playing
in Fusion Tables and then copying the embed
code, dropping it on your website. You know,
it doesn't allow you to customize--a customizability
of a Maps API site, say, I want a Styled Map
and a Fusion Tables map to show up. While
in v3, we have this class called Fusion Tables
layer which lets you create a layer on top
of Fusion--on top the Maps API v3 that draws
directly from Fusion Tables. In Fusion Tables,
the way you query Fusion Tables is just standard
SQL. So a lot of developers know SQL. I imagine
a lot of you are pretty familiar with it.
So it's very, very easy to render data on
top of the map and play with that data. So,
let's take a look at this dataset in Iraq.
So you can tell that this a Maps API site
because I have a little styled option that
I created that sort of tones down the data.
You can also see that I styled the points
differently so a different color shows up.
Red had more deaths in that incident and then
blue had fewer. But I can also do an arbitrary
query. So I'm going to query over the column,
total deaths. I'm going to change this to
a four. And you can see less data is displayed
on the map. And again, the heat map functionality
is also available via the Fusion Tables layer.
And this isn't really an accurate representation
of a heat map because each point can represent
many wound--casualties and injuries. Remember
our Brazilian beaches dataset? This is just
an example of me loading that here and enabling
the heat map. I don't have any query here
because all I want to throw is the entire
dataset so I don't need to supply a query.
And if you look at congressional district
demographics as I zoom in--oh, I did not want
to click that. This dataset is available here.
Let's say I wanted to actually, you know,
in real time, build a site where people can
explore this dataset, you can do that. And
it's super fast, right? I just am now restricting
by some arbitrary number. I want where this
is over 38 and it will show only the results
that are over 38. So, we did a--and I'll let
you explore this. I'll share this deck, this
presentation, but we also have an example
up there which is polling results--polling
predictions for the United States--the upcoming
elections on November 2 in the United Sates.
And it uses Fusion Tables and styling and
custom info windows and the Fusion Tables
layer in Maps API v3. So we're really excited
about Fusion Tables. I think you should play
around with it, really explore. It's very,
very powerful. It becomes very, very easy
to do a lot of things that were very hard
to do without some sort of cloud-based database
that has a very strong integration with our
Maps API. So, I want to touch on a couple
new launches in Earth. I don't know how many
of you are familiar with the Earth API. I
imagine most of you are familiar with Google
Earth. The Earth API lets you embed Earth
in a browser and has a JavaScript API to let
you control the user experience. So you can
now have users come to your site, embed Earth
there or present data on Earth as you would
in the Google Earth downloaded application
but on a Web site. The Earth API is a plug-in.
It has over 100 million installs. It's being
bundled with Google Earth so the install base
is growing. But you should be aware that it
is a plug-in. So we released the Earth API
several years ago, two or three years ago,
and the team has been focusing on performance
and browser compatibility. But we also added
a couple of new features. One is access to
our historical imagery. And we have a lot
of historical satellite imagery. I looked
in Brazil like--it went back to 19--sorry,
it went back to 2000 so it didn't go back
that far. But in San Francisco, it goes back
quite a bit. There's a satellite--well, probably
not a satellite--imagery taken from an aircraft
from 1946. So we have access to it. But you
can do a lot of really compelling things with
this imagery, with the imagery that we have.
So in 1989, there was a major earthquake in
San Francisco. I just want to show you sort
of what's--what a story you can present with
historical imagery. There is this, you know,
on-ramp, this highway in 1988. It looks all
great. As I move forward to 1990 and let the
imagery load--running a bit slow. All right.
So this imagery in 1994, as this loads--there
we go--you can see that, you know, this structure
collapsed in the earthquake and then they
tore it down. And so, they're still this end
of a freeway. And if you jump all the way
to current day, you see, you know, the freeway
is gone. There's just now a pretty, like,
an on-ramp with some trees. But you can still
see the scar in the city, right? It's left
a visible scar. These are all parking lots
that opened up in the scar of where that freeway
on-ramp was. So we now give you access to
this data via the Earth API. So, I can programmatically
say set the time, jump this back to 2000,
enable the actual time machine, which is what
we call the historical imagery interface,
enable and disable the UI. So I can define
the user experience however I want. One thing
I want to mention last, KML, we launched a
new feature Track. We wanted an easy way for--to
be able to represent motion both on the planet
and above. And previously, there was a way
to do this in KML. It involved creating a
placemark, associating a time with it, and
then creating another placemark and another
time with it, to denote movements of, you
know, a particular point or object. That is
no longer necessary with that. It wasn't really
movement of a placemark. It was just one placemark
created, another placemark created; the older
one deleted. Now, we have an ability to represent
time on through Track. So, a lot less code.
It's basically just to parallel arrays; one
with the time and the other one with the points.
This is running a bit slow but it's just an
imagery of a plane using Track to sort of
fly around. This has advantages for you, the
developer, because it's a lot easier to produce
this KML code. It also has advantages for
us because it's now a lot, lot quicker for
us to render movements on both the Earth API
and the Earth client. So that's--oh, right.
I wanted to mention the Latitude API. I'm
not going to go into this in much detail.
Latitude is--if you have an Android phone,
it's a product that you can turn on that tracks
your location and you can share a location
with friends. There's also an API that lets
developers access your location, both to set
it and get it. And you can get both the best
available or just city level location, you
can authorize what you want that application
to have access to. It's not a competitor to
the HTML5 Geolocation API. It is a way for
applications to know where you are without
you having to be on a Web site using a browser
because it's pushed from your phone. A couple
of interesting used cases, the one up here,
somebody built an application that based on
if you're traveling away from your home or
traveling--or coming home, changes the temperature,
so that you're not wasting energy heating
a house with nobody there. This one right
here, geotags your photos based on a time
stamp if your camera doesn't have that capability.
That's what I wanted to cover. I know there's
a lot of--many things. I just sort of gives
you an idea of how many Geospatial technologies
we have at Google. And the deck is up here.
If you want to see the first presentation,
it's at Geo1. And I suggest you load this
in Chrome or they don't work very well, otherwise.
And the relevant links for the things I showed.
Also, please fill out this feedback. And I
am open to talking any questions. All right.
Thanks very much for your time.